all right speed round peter as we get
through the rest of the sunday games we
talked a little bit about the covet 19
issues that will affect the baltimore
ravens
more pressure on the ravens at
indianapolis to rebound or on the colts
to show that they can play with the big
boys
more pressure on the ravens with their
lineup challenges with five defensive
starters
being away from the team all week
because of covid precautions
they've got to show up and play
a very good offense with phillip rivers
having new life and their running game
has to figure a way to have a 200-yard
day again against the number two defense
in football more pressure on the ravens
yeah i agree with you that the ravens do
have to show that they can get past that
loss from last week they did a good job
after they lost to the chiefs in week
three on monday night they didn't let
that turn into two losses last year they
did let their loss to the chiefs turn
into a second loss when they got beaten
soundly at home by the browns so they've
shown they can recover from a deflating
loss and there's a lot of good in that
film they outplayed the steelers you go
back and watch that game it's like how
in the hell do the ravens lose this game
so i think they should feel confident
but there is pressure on them because
peter
their next three games before the
steelers rematch on thanksgiving night
much more difficult than the steelers
next three games before that rematch
bingo that's not a big you know so you
know i'll i'll i'll i'll go easy on the
control room on a friday you had to
force a bingo in that's fine i mentioned
the steelers the steelers going to
dallas for another game that they could
play every year with 17 on the schedule
wouldn't we love to see the black and
gold against the blue star on the silver
helmet more frequently one of the great
inner conference rivalries in football
not this year steelers undefeated
cowboys thoroughly defeated and it's
going to be and this is the nfl's
version of the lloyd braun george
costanza computer selling contest as
garrett gilbert and cooper rush vie for
the opportunity to get pummeled by the
steelers defense whoever starts at
quarterback for the cowboys will what
peter get that off get off the screen
not be within 14 points of the of the
pittsburgh steelers i i you know what
the the greatest stat of the week mike
is that
the pittsburgh steelers go to dallas and
the cowboys have not been double-digit
home dogs
in a half century
and
yet i would take pittsburgh even if the
line was 20.
i just would and because i don't know
what dallas can do on offense right now
to keep this game even remotely close so
i mean this is going to be one of those
games like almost last night turn away
just please turn away
look away i'm hideous uh this this is
look away i'm hideous
this is a potential trap game for the
steelers if it wasn't dallas if it
wasn't the cowboys if it wasn't
america's team in that giant stadium
with 25 000 fans present and ben
roethlisberger has never won there he
lost a super bowl there he lost to the
cowboys there in the regular season
after that so this would be a great
opportunity for someone to catch the
steelers napping they're going to be
wide awake and fully caffeinated in that
stadium even though the cowboys aren't
any good all right panthers at the
chiefs patrick mahomes through eight
games this year has been what peter
you know
an mvp in any other year but this one
you know
uh i think
there's so many quarterbacks playing so
well and right now it'd probably be
russell wilson aaron rodgers or patrick
mahomes
i'd take wilson but i wouldn't
bat an eye if you wanted to take either
the other two guys
patrick mahomes right now is getting to
the point where he's boringly great
every weekend
and i just think we're watching the
michael jordan of pro football right now
and that isn't to say anything bad about
anybody else who plays
maybe russell wilson is kobe bryant
and uh and and and who's another great
player aaron rodgers is durant or the
old larry bird i don't know
but
there is such great quarterbacking right
now in the nfl that sometimes we forget
that we're watching i i think once we
all stop watching pro football whatever
day that is whatever day they put us
into the cold cold ground the day before
that will say patrick mahomes is one of
the best we ever saw
well and i think patrick mahomes likes
being overlooked and forgotten last year
when he had that injury against the
broncos on a thursday night and missed a
couple of games the game moves on lamar
jackson emerges as the mvp because
patrick mahomes wasn't playing and i
remember when they beat the broncos in
the snow
in december i spoke to mahomes after the
game i said you kind of like this vibe
where no one's really paying attention
he said i really like this vibe where no
one's really paying attention and what
happens they win the super bowl so yeah
i think mahomes uh has been spectacular
but we are beginning to take it for
granted because he set a bar
that that we just expect him to meet and
he meets it each and every week so we
get fascinated by somebody else who's
performing at a new level that we hadn't
before seen like russell wilson all
right the raiders taking on the chargers
in la if this game had fans present it
would be overrun
by silver and black anthony lynn's job
security is currently what peter
i think it's better than 50 50 he'll be
back but again you know
in week nine there's so much football
left to be played that if they keep
blowing games like this he's not going
to be back
because at some point the buck stops
with the head coach it's just like we
were talking about john gruden the buck
stops with the head coach on this covet
deal
he's got to make it right inside his
team period
and as far as anthony lynn goes you know
you cannot lose 17 point leads every
week and that's what they do better
figure out a way to do it or yeah or
somebody else is going to be coaching
the team next year
0 and 3 with the 17 point lead it's
happened three out of the last four
games
at tampa at new orleans and they had
their buy they beat the jaguars who
hasn't other than the cults and then it
happened again to the charges this past
weekend against the broncos i i think
that when and this is the curse of
having a great young quarterback
because this is a hell of an opportunity
now for the chargers to hire an a-plus
list coach because what's the first
criteria for any head coach with options
peter
what's my situation at quarterback and
when justin herbert has shown what he's
shown so far this year
this is an opportunity and i hate to say
this because i really have a ton of
respect for anthony lynn but this is an
opportunity for the chargers to upgrade
a coach much like the colts did when
they had a young franchise quarterback
and peyton manning moved on from jim
mora the elder got tony dungey and the
rest is history okay bears at the titan
here's can i just say one one last thing
about this mike if you look at the the
coaching availabilities in the
off-season
you look at the new york jets first and
you just say okay who's going to want to
come coach trevor lawrence that's a
great situation you look at the houston
texans they're kind of bad you know
they're in a bad
situation cap wise and and they got some
older players but
you got deshawn watson that's a
situation for a great offensive coach i
mean there's already two places that is
that are going to be looked for code
that are going to look for coaches and
that is even before you look at the
chargers and what might may or may not
happen with anthony lynn
yeah i'd be concerned about houston
because no first round or second round
pick this year miami has that and also i
want to know who the gm is and i want to
know what jack easterby's role is going
to be going forward before i take that
job in houston but you're right when you
go to a place with a franchise
quarterback you're better off and
usually these jobs don't have either a
current franchise quarterback or a
potential one in a trevor lawrence ready
to go okay bears titans both teams have
lost two in a row both teams had five
wins before they started their losing
streaks who's more in trouble if they
lose and extend that streak to three
peter
bears um because the bears if they lose
again
uh you're looking at the possibility of
a free fall with no solution at
quarterback
and you know look
nick foles has always been the great
relief pitcher
but when you give him a chance to be the
full-time starter
you know only one time the year the
dream year he had in philadelphia only
one time has he been great so to me
especially
with when you look at the packers and
look their next game is jacksonville at
home the green bay packers are going to
be seven and two
uh you know nine days from now the
chicago bears if they lose this game at
five and four
they're going to be two games
off in the loss column i do not see with
their offense how in the world they can
make that up against the green bay
packers
and when you've got three legitimate
playoff contenders in the nfc west and
two in the nfc south even with a 17
field if you're the bears you're the
team that's on the outside looking in so
i agree with you the titans can still
work it out the bears and i feel bad for
nick foles he doesn't have any
protection what's he supposed to do the
offensive line is horrible and they've
got covet issues and injury issues on
the offensive line in chicago
this week all right
last game lions at the vikings the
winner of this game and if it's the
lions they're four and four if it's the
vikings they're three and five the
winner is what peter
i think the winner really helps
the coach of that team
continue to be able to send the message
that the season's not over
and
you know the way i look at this is mike
obviously matt patricia's coaching for
his job mike zimmer is not mike zimmer's
going to be back next year
in all all likelihood
but matt patricia's coaching for his job
and to me
especially with the difficulty he's
going to have this week in not having
matthew stafford available until game
day
that to me is really really troublesome
for the lions and i look at one thing
when i look at the minnesota vikings
right now mike
everybody said oh my god how did they go
to green bay
and beat the green bay packers it just
that was the most unlikely result of the
week certainly but
you know what i say at some point last
week mike zimmer sidled up to his
offensive staff
you know
clearly he sidled up to the decision
makers
on offense and he basically said hey
listen
this is going to be a running game
let us run the ball and they give it to
dalvin cook dalvin has 32 touches in
this game and what did they do they know
right now to not put the game in kirk
cousins hands he touched he throws 14
passes
and obviously the the the vikings go in
and win so to me
when i look at this team there's such a
better team when they are run oriented
if this is a 60 40 run game for the
minnesota vikings they're going to win
this game
and they've got a couple of former
vikings coming to town to make it even
more interesting adrian peterson and
everson griffin i think the loser of
this game is done i don't know what to
think about the winner of this game
because there's too many other great
teams in the nfc that need to be caught
if you want to try to parlay that
victory into something in the second
half but i think the loser for all
practical purposes is going to be done
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports